the blind ranking of college football
jerseys I can't change my mind it's
Colorado State 10 side Tennessee not as
cold number two that's code Jersey man
that's hard to beat right there Houston
yeah that's cold too but it kind of like
oh miss number four number four number
four we got room to improve Michigan
State number nine that joke is loud but
you say oh that oranges it's cold too
number six oh whatever haters now that's
cool it's like a lot number eight no I
should have waited bro hey number seven
dang I should have waited oh my God no
way yeah number five UCLA number three
Morgan uniforms go crazy that's number
one for sure we did every team but
Colorado come on